i performed strip club too i performed
at a strip club and the guy was trying
to promote the knight
it was the worst name ever right he was
calling it giggles and jingles
[Music]
so it would go comic it would go
[Music]
and a comic walks on stage and you're
not expecting comedy
[Music]
[Applause]
was like coming to the stage
no nobody knew it was coming
please welcome
josh wolf
[Music]
and it was
just dead silence
dead sound right because you can see the
guys like
and i walked on stage
and during the first girl he was just
throwing about the girls like crazy
right
standing up and throwing you know those
of you who have been to a strip club
before you know when you're up on
sniffer's road like where's [ __ ]
[Applause]
so
this dude's up here
[Music]
you know one eye drunk you know
you know what i'm talking about where
only one eye is working blinking
everything
so jim was one eye drop and he stands up
and i walked out
and i go hey everybody he stands up and
he goes
you're the ugliest chick i've ever seen
[Music]
just to make it to another twenty four
twenty five perhaps i got me constantly
smoking i'm getting high just to balance
out the lows
and they always tell me that i should be
living better i suppose
but you know how the story goes another
day another dollar howler 7 p.m what's
it gonna break another bug now